foreign 5.
let the wise hear an increase in
learning
and the one who understands obtain
guidance
to understand a proverb and a saying
the words of the wise and their riddles
the fear of the Lord is the beginning of
knowledge
fools despise wisdom and instruction
Proverbs 3 verse 5 trust in the Lord
with all your heart and do not lean on
your own understanding in all your ways
acknowledge Him and He will make
straight your paths being are wise in
your own eyes fear the lord and turn
away from evil
you will be healing to your flesh and
refreshment to your bones
Proverbs 27 verse 1.
do not boast about tomorrow
for you do not know what a day may bring
let another praise you and not your own
mouth
a stranger and not your own lips
proverbs 4 23.
keep your heart with all vigilance for
from it flow the Springs of Life
put away from you crooked speech
and put devious talk far from you
let your eyes look directly forward
and your gaze be straight before you
Ponder the path of your feet
then all your ways will be sure do not
swerve to the right or to the left turn
your foot away from evil
Proverbs 28 verse 13.
whoever conceals his transgressions will
not prosper
but he who confesses and forsakes them
will obtain Mercy
lest is the one who fears the lord
always but whoever hardens his heart
will fall into calamity
Proverbs 24 16.
for the righteous falls seven times and
rises again
[Music]
but the wicked stumble in times of
calamity
do not rejoice when your enemy Falls
let not your heart be glad when he
stumbles
lest the Lord see it and be displeased
and turn away his anger from him fret
not yourself because of evil doers and
be not envious of the wicked
for the evil man has no future the lamp
of the wicked will be put out
Proverbs 16 verse 5.
everyone who is arrogant in heart is an
Abomination to the Lord
be assured he will not go unpunished
by steadfast love and faithfulness
iniquity is atoned for
and by the fear of the Lord one turns
away from evil
when a man's ways please the Lord
he makes even his enemies to be at peace
with him better is a little with
righteousness
than great revenues with Injustice the
heart of man plans his way
but the Lord establishes his steps
Proverbs 22 verse 1.
a good name is to be chosen rather than
great riches
and favor is better than silver or gold
the rich and the poor meet together
the Lord is the maker of them all
The Prudent sees danger and hides
himself
but the simple
go on and suffer for it
the reward for humility and fear of the
Lord is riches and honor and life
thorns and snares are in the way of the
crooked
whoever guards his soul will keep far
from them
train up a child in the way he should go
even when he is old
he will not depart from him
Proverbs 27 17.
iron sharpens iron
one man sharpens another
verse 19 says as in water
face reflects face
so the heart of man
reflects the man
Proverbs 17 verse 22.
a joyful heart is good medicine
but a crushed Spirit dries up the bones
the wicked accepts a bribe in secret to
pervert the ways of Justice the
Discerning sets his face toward wisdom
by the eyes of a fool are on the ends of
the Earth
a foolish son is a grief to his father
and bitterness to her Who Bore him
Proverbs 6 6.
[Music]
go to the end o sluggart
consider her ways and be wise
without having any chief officer or
ruler she prepares her bread in summer
and gathers her food in Harvest
how long will you lie there oh sluggard
when will you arise from your sleep a
little sleep a little Slumber a little
folding of the hands to rest
and poverty will come upon you like a
robber
and want like an armed man
Proverbs 13 verse 1.
a wise son hears his father's
instruction
but a scoffer does not listen to rebuke
from the fruit of his mouth a man eats
what is good
but the desire of the treacherous is for
violence
whoever guards his mouth preserves his
life
he who opens wide his lips comes to ruin
Proverbs 9 verse 8.
do not reprove a scoffer or he will hate
you
reprove a wise man and he will love you
give instruction to a wise man and he
will be still wiser
teach a righteous man and he will
increase in learning
proverbs 18.
a fool takes no pleasure in
understanding
but only in expressing his opinion
when wickedness comes contempt comes
also
and with this honor comes disgrace the
words of a man's mouth
are deep Waters
the Fountain of wisdom is a bubbling
brook
Proverbs 6 16.
there are six things that the Lord hates
seven that are an Abomination to him
hearty eyes
a lying tongue
and hands that shed innocent blood
a heart that devises Wicked plans feet
that make haste to run to evil
a false witness who breathes out lies
and one who sows Discord among Brothers
Proverbs 15 verse 1 a soft answer turns
away wrath but a harsh word stirs up
anger
the tongue of the wise commands
knowledge but the mouths of fools pour
out folly
the eyes of the Lord are in every place
keeping watch on the evil and the good
[Music]
Proverbs 13 22 a good man leaves an
inheritance to his children's children
by the Sinners wealth is laid up for the
righteous the fallow ground of the poor
would yield much food but it is Swept
Away through Injustice
Proverbs 20 verse 5.
the purpose in a man's heart is like
deep water
but a man of understanding will draw it
out
many a man proclaims his own steadfast
love
but a faithful man who can find
the righteous who walks in his Integrity
blessed are his children after him
Proverbs 13 verse 24. whoever spares the
rod hates his son but he who loves him
is diligent to discipline him
Proverbs 20 verse 19. whoever goes about
slandering reveals secrets
therefore do not associate with a simple
babbler if one curses his father or his
mother his lamp will be put out in utter
Darkness
Proverbs 18 verse 19. a brother offended
is more unyielding than a strong City
and quarreling is like the bars of a
castle
from the fruit of a man's mouth his
stomach is satisfied
he is Satisfied by the yield of his lips
death and life are in the power of the
tongue and those who love it will eat
its fruits
Proverbs 14 verse 12.
there is a way that seems right to a man
at its end is the way to death
even in laughter the heart May ache
and the end of Joy may be grief
Proverbs 18 verse 24.
a man of many companions may come to
ruin but there is a friend who sticks
closer than a brother
Proverbs 15 verse 28 the heart of the
righteous Ponders how to answer
but the mouth of the wicked pours out
evil things
the Lord is far from the wicked but he
hears the prayer of the righteous
Proverbs 14 15.
the simple believes everything
but The Prudent gives thought to his
steps
one who is wise is cautious
and turns away from evil
but a fool is reckless and careless
a man of quick temper acts foolishly
and the man of evil devices is hated
the simple inherent folly
but The Prudent or crowned
with knowledge